the Joe Rogan experience speaking of
aspirin is he awake yet he's awake
talking he's uh he handled it like a
champion oh good yeah he went on Ariel
Helwani show and talked about it and she
said yeah it sucks the guy's a douche
bag like sucks losing to him uh you know
I don't like him he said you know he
just what can he do he's right he's not
gonna read the comments
he's a smart man he's a very smart guy
but he took it like a man to be able to
go and do an interview right after you
get knocked out like that it's very
admirable but that's who he is that's
how you get to be a guy who's as good a
wrestler as a guy like Ben Askren I can
handle a loss like that what do you
think of the figure I can't I can't
pronounce the guy's name who beat him
Jorge Masvidal
Maz without what he said after the fight
he said he would smack him if you saw
him at Whole Foods
yeah I think I think it's just a little
too much u1i but I don't know their
history the history is rough excuse me
it's like ten years of them giving him a
hard time
or if Ben Askren giving miles at all
according to Maz Vidal a lot of talking
[ __ ] which some people think is friendly
in Maz Vidale Street Jesus doesn't [ __ ]
around all right jeez
Street Jesus he will [ __ ] make fun
even after he flatlines Yeah right
and that's what I did he flatlined him
in five seconds made him the fastest
ever ko in UFC history and then mocked
him afterwards and said he would smack
him if he saw him at Whole Foods but see
we're talking about it
so Maas Vidal is smart this is a yeah
yeah this is a amazing marketing ploy I
mean he's he's become in one fight the
most talked-about fighter in the sport
because he did something in the sport
that's been around for a little bit that
nobody's ever done before
yeah Ben Askren was undefeated yeah
undefeated and Maz Vidale comes out flat
lines like that and talks some pretty
vicious [ __ ] after the fact and even
mimicked him laying on the floor yeah
which would look scary the way he was
out mm-hmm yeah Martha Dahl was saying
calls out easy Conor McGregor I want to
break his face
yeah that would be that's a rough fight
that's a rough fight for Connor Maas
Woodall is a big fella too I mean he's
he really belongs at 170 that's where
he's fighting he fought at 155 but
really tortured himself to make that
wait all right he's a big guy you're
talking about a guy who knocked out
cowboy Cerrone knocked out dere until
knocked out Ben Askren mean he's
knocking out big welterweights big dare
until is a big welterweight he's big
he's not a guy coming up from 155 pounds
he's never making hundreds could be he's
weigh 55
155 sorry yeah so he's one weight class
heavier and he's really running into
like the last few fights he's at least
coming into his own he's really becoming
something special he had a real close
decision loss to wonder boy I wish I
could remember how that fight went down
I just think it was a decision I don't
know if it was a split decision or
unanimous decision but I think it was
just wonder boy outpointed him I don't
think there was any knockdowns right no
smiles oh yeah I was monster doll but
wonder boy is a particularly difficult
guy to fight and especially for three
rounds
Pettis recently knocked him out but pet
it's just hit him with a perfect punch
and that can happen to anybody and
Pettis timed it and Pettis is a beast
this is Wow
yeah he's a wild man here he's a
fantastic fighter losing to him it's
like yeah you lost him one of the best
fighters ever and he also like he's a
guy who dropped Tony Ferguson I mean pet
is knocked out cowboy Cerrone Pettit's
knocked out cholos armed with his crazy
head chain that is a monster
[Applause]